[Music]
Hey hello hello everyone
Zaha layer rogue 6000 creek so Stuart
pan warden venom solving donkey to and
everyone else who is quickly joining in
so hello everyone
yeah this is just a short birthday
stream that I'm going to do for like
maybe maybe now or maybe two we'll see
how it goes
and you guys are welcome to challenge me
we're gonna we're gonna play some games
and then I have to go yeah you know I
have a birthday we're gonna have a nice
meal and you know Oh everything that
follows so a key gene Keith Roger hello
man how are you doing
Varun Kumar Alisha P Melly Harsha BR
reached Saurav yeah hello hello once
again and let's check if we do have some
challenges like you can challenge to
pretty much any time format if it's
three minutes plus zero seconds
increment otherwise you know might might
take a bit too long like maybe okay an
occasional five-minute game is okay you
can challenge the bullet game it's not a
problem and we're just gonna go in some
let's say normal order okay so first
game is against the oksana bolo Boca so
good luck man
and let's see let's see what happens
thank you everyone for the for the
lovely wishes and not only here but also
also on all of my social media really
just overwhelming me with the the best
wishes X Big Willie thanks for the
contribution man yes it was in this
position that you've donated and it
seems oxen Ibaka is not here so we are
going to abort this game check out some
other game ok these are two day games to
the games to the games White King chest
alright white king chest again I get the
white pieces Yash thank you for the
contribution Yash alright it's it's a
birthday stream so
we have to play exciting opening so
we're gonna go for the Kings gambit
right away that's that's that's good
night of six let's see what what black
comes up with all right thank you thank
you everyone all right he castles and
it's it's he he doesn't want to play the
the the accepted King's gambit so it's
not not a problem we're just gonna
develop played this get the bishop here
and then just castle and it's a it's a
reasonably playable position okay now he
pins me he wants to go knight c6 and go
here so I'm just gonna kick that night
away from there don't really feel like
leaving it there he's gonna have to
capture probably if he goes here I'm
just gonna win his piece and we'll see
what happens yeah he has the capture and
now he wants to again go here not gonna
let him have to make some room for c3 d4
and yeah we'll see we'll see how it goes
probably gonna cast a queen side now
he's really not letting me Castle
kingside it's very sneaky going for that
sea-doo pawn I'm just gonna go Bishop b3
keep an eye on everything here nicely
and continued Vishal Sharma thanks a lot
it's okay it's okay thanks for the
contribution
whenever I win my opponent just lets me
win because it's my birthday yeah
probably probably but I don't mind I
don't mind there are worse ways to spend
your birthday Vivek gee thank you for
the contribution man okay so we've
kicked away the night now we are gonna
go still haven't decided I'm still gonna
go d3 yeah just nice the three Bishop e3
and castles King side we're gonna
get my bishop here very similar on time
so we'll see we'll see what happens
could be could be one of the weirder
King Kings gamble games I've played yeah
okay I have to trade here kick away the
district let's go Bishop III and then
just nicely Castle kingside maybe he's
gonna capture here that's fine we have a
beautiful Bishop here so let's just
castle bring the other rook into the
game and should be should be a good game
maybe we can even double up on the F
file we'll see how it goes
thank you once again everyone I would
mention everyone's name but I wouldn't
be able to play sowhat's c6 he wants to
play this I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
kick it away and should be okay I'm just
gonna go Queen g5 here and make a threat
right away I'm just gonna make a threat
here and see what he goes for maybe he
weakens the King a little bit which is
fine if not we'll we'll see basically
just trying to get him to spend some
time geez the quarter you also have a
birthday have a happy birthday man okay
he spots my move I guess I could capture
here I'm just gonna capture here and go
for this check and bring my rook into
the game I don't think he will have
sufficient counter play here yeah I just
get get the rook in there
the bishop still slices all the way here
very nicely I don't see a way for him to
okay there's a rook here but yeah now
it's just Rock f5 and okay he could play
h6 I don't really mind but yeah I think
I think this is just game over okay
good game man mr. white King chest
just play thanks for the contribution
man it was it was a weird King the
gamble game but let's let's say he he of
course let me win as it is my birthday
all right we have chess master five nine
eight seven
all right I'm gonna go for the
Scandinavian as that that can be
considered that could be considered
exciting let me just check what happened
there no idea something fell but I don't
know what all right so we've wasted some
time but Scandinavian doesn't require
you to have a lot of time I guess so it
should be okay I'm gonna go a six take
away this square yeah metal probably did
something krishna Pandey thanks for the
contribution man let's go bash up here
alright immediately going with with the
bishop move okay I guess I guess I guess
we go I guess we move the the Queen
create a double attack he he's gonna go
bash up GT so don't really know how how
well thought this was utter Singha
thanks for conversion and does he have
any discoveries that should frighten me
I don't think so he might
I just don't think so
okay that's always a possibility I'm
just gonna go threatened threatened the
b-pawn here I don't really have any any
wishes to actually capture it and he
wants to trade here that's interesting
I'm just gonna castle here allow him to
trade
okay so Queens are almost off the board
I guess we we capture here not the best
now he has to trade yeah
it'd be better if if I could grab the
bishop good to check but should be okay
once the onesy the the amount
thanks for the conversion man alright
Bishop captures and now we win the pawn
by going Knight captures here I still
have to develop one of my bishops
but should be okay stab the mixtape
would thanks a lot man thanks for the
contribution okay so we want a pawn
should be okay yes the stab be mixed up
would drew Sharma thanks a lot thanks
for the contribution and also Annie
thanks a lot man alright so he's
starting to spend some time as we did
win a pawn so he has to figure out how
to how to proceed and yeah that's that's
good we're just gonna play this right
he's probably gonna kick away my knight
with c4 at some point I get my bishop in
maybe double rooks on the e-file and we
should be we should be okay here castle
wanna thank you thank you for the
contribution I will do my best to have a
good one okay he wants to go beef before
I don't really mind that I'm just gonna
just gonna double up here not really
worried about putting my rook on a light
Square still just gonna go here
challenge the rook
not all that many squares for the rook
available he has to go here if he
doesn't go here he's gonna lose the
exchange so not not the bow he goes here
okay I will I will have some of that
action thank you oh okay I see what he's
doing
yeah that that also works yeah I kind of
missed that he has Bishop characters
here that's a good move okay he didn't
want to go for it all right
he's his Oh he's letting me off the hook
easy okay so it's bishops of opposite
colors and I'm very low on time so let's
just get that King into the game put
everything on a dark square yeah I don't
have a way of creating some sort of a
barrier along the dark squares and I
really don't want to trade rooks but
maybe I could trade rooks let's say I
trade rooks and yeah that's actually not
very smart okay but I do have this
covered so it's not really that big of
an issue yeah let's go for that pawn
let's block it yeah you will not thou
shalt not pass
and now let's let's push our own pawn
make sense still cannot block it let's
push it 27 seconds probably gonna be
some sort of a flag off but I'm not
really worried as long as my bishop is
here let's save that pawn no need to
blunder it right away let's go in go in
with the King and there we go
shrine mom would thank you for the
contribution man we go in with the King
we push away his rook and we win so this
was this was very yeah I might have just
missed it but okay if this then I have
worked here so it's not a problem and he
still will not be able to cross any dark
square see I'm just gonna block the pawn
this way yeah the pawns not crossing
next move I'm gonna play King here yeah
that's game thank you and he will try to
flag me with one second but I am pretty
decent with 11 seconds against against
the third of a second so good game man
was a very very very intense I'm gonna
have a nice sip of water thanks a lot
guys
all right let's check another one
ah we have Verado Vlad is here
what are displaying every tournament we
have every Friday he he plays D and D
Friday arena and he goes for the
Scandinavian I like it how do we go
let's see which one does he play he goes
for this one okay I'm gonna do my best
he's copying he's playing my moves
that's cool
okay he makes room for the he makes a
room for the Queen and we go
g3 now I never liked the Bishop f4 idea
against against the Scandinavian but I
will try it against varada and see what
happens yeah okay I see your point
d5 square is a pretty good square for
the knight alright we'll see if we can
take advantage of this Queens position
here
probably not he's going after my beat
you pawn am I worried about the b2 pawn
not really or kind of feels weird
guarding that b2 pawn but
now let's continue harassing that Queen
that kind of makes sense
check yeah let's harass the Queen we're
gonna block this next kick away the
Queen with b4 might be a little bit
risky but I am trying to take away some
squares from the black queen
as he still didn't even start developing
the Kings side and might be a bit risky
to Castle queenside but but we'll see
okay he goes for that I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna do what exactly
yeah let's let's get rid of his Queen
yeah he has to go all the way back and
now we threatened the b7 pawn I guess
but then he has b6 it's not not the the
most impressive move yeah okay let's
just nicely develop Bishop to d3 I don't
mind him capturing the dark square
bishop here okay he wants the castle of
course he does let's go here threaten
both of these guys yeah okay he defends
that he defends it and we're gonna go
Queen e2 now or yeah let's castle here
we go f4 f5 makes sense very long time
very long time scatter and go okay still
can't capture here but I can do this
kick away the Queen and then go f5 I
guess maybe b5 is an idea yeah he's
doing much better on time so he's doing
much better on time so I hope my f5 idea
will be will be something yeah okay
let's first get rid of that Queen not
allow any checks go away go away Queen
all right sue Schinder viage thank you
for the contribution man and should er
Subramanya and thanks a lot man okay so
let's push a five now and hope for the
best
I guess we're threatening to just open
up the position it's not much but it's
it is something okay that's interesting
let's go King G - it's probably gonna
push at some point trying to close my
light square bishop yeah I like his
position but unfortunately I have to
play mine
yeah let's capture here put some
pressure on this rook here let's go here
trade and try try and make this f7 pawn
a weakness yeah I've kind of allowed him
to capture this so hopefully I have
something like like maybe Queen d3 queen
g4 hoping that he blunders something
yeah 39 seconds on the clock it's not
gonna be easy and he does thank you sir
whoa no I blundered he opened up the
Queen Wow
I totally missed his idea good job man
good job Wow
let me let me check that in slow motion
yeah I prepared it and he he played c5
and the defender the g6 pawn and I was
already very happy that he blundered
however the blunder was mine all right
good game Vlad we have Leon melon okay
good job man
I thought I thought his c-pawn move was
just about closing up my bishops
diagonal however however it was much
more yeah I was the nastiest of
discoveries Annie thank you for the
contribution man thanks a lot
so hinder voyage also thanks a lot man
all right so we have to play exciting
stuff we go for B for I still haven't
checked the Jerome what what is the the
Jerome I I see a lot of people are are
mentioning it but I still haven't
haven't checked it out all right so he
spent a lot of time declining my b4 pawn
very very interesting let's go here
all right night back to g8 okay that is
definitely interesting night back to g8
that is that is quite the move yep
it was it was in this position that I
resigned but in the previous game not
not in this one all right so he wants
the fee in Cairo now but now it might be
a bit dangerous since we can just I
guess capture here and play east six
it's not gonna be very pleasant
hopefully he captures with the Queen but
he doesn't he captures with the night so
he still gets the block but it's not the
the most pleasant of positions now it's
it's very ugly Leslie thank you for the
contribution Leslie alright so what kind
of damage are we hoping to do here well
a lot of a lot of possibilities here
let's just Castle first I don't I don't
think this do this does add anything
actually I mean it's probably playable
it's just not not all that great let's
take away the Queen from here
yeah that's that's very interesting
huh
yeah probably could have could have
exploited that better all right he goes
for the roof let's close this not not
interested in let him letting him open
up the position too early let's go for
this d4 move simply to to not allow him
to block my night okay
that's possible yeah now hmm yeah he
wants to play this I guess which which
isn't bad and I don't really have a good
way of stopping it but I think f4i
even giving up the f4 pawn I think it's
a it's a nice idea
just to just to open up some lines yeah
now we go here yeah we give up this
point as well mark and sell back thank
you for the contribution man and also
the chef thanks a lot mr. chef all right
so how do we how do we get more people
into the attack we do have some pressure
here so let's get this rook here
now we're pressuring this we're
pressuring this the bishop is very
strong could be okay he wants to he
wants to do a lot of damage of course he
does so let's just go here yeah and also
he's probably gonna try and check made
me somehow by getting his Queen in there
yeah but it's not easy okay this is very
interesting this is very interesting
however it's also a piece blunder yeah
so I guess we just capture it and I mean
yeah but we're also extremely low on
time so oh he has that ah that's
interesting I guess okay yeah now we we
have to hurry
yeah you guys you guys were way off when
you said that people people would let me
win because it's my birthday not even
the slightest yeah let's go for that
let's capture this guy okay we're up
piece 18 seconds should be enough to
exploit being up a piece or not alright
let's let's use those seconds wisely
all right not a lot of time but yeah
he's not gonna just let me grab it okay
Wow oh man I'm getting I'm getting
flagged yeah ha ha yeah that was not
enough time okay good job mr. Leon melon
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
pay more attention in the next one all
right drop aureus Bart of course our
thanks a lot man for the 40 contribution
all right
now we now we play serious moves only
thanks a lot guys all right let's go for
the Queen what do we go for here trap
aureus okay now everyone is playing this
line of the Scandinavian that's that's
super interesting and E 5 the immediate
'if I've I've never actually encountered
this but I guess it does make sense
I'm sure it's bad for some reason I just
don't know why probably we need to we
need to bust open the position or like
immediately as it does look it does look
very bold yeah ok it's um it's a poem so
oh it's not even a pawn he gets the cap
from I see to pawn but I get at the
capture on f7 later on so I guess it is
interesting ok and yeah let's attack the
bishop yeah he's gonna go back with the
bishop here so what's the point huh yeah
there's there's no actual point here
I have to defend my night on d1 if I
went 93 he'd just go back and defend the
f7 pawn so this way we we make some
problems maybe thank you thank you
everyone are you you can join by just
the clicking well not clicking anything
basically but just you can just go to
leech s and challenge me alright
oh it's my turn yeah he goes bishop g6
of course he wants to defend it let's
get our look to see c1 in front of the
King may be some pressure is possible
here it's hard to say but okay and do I
capture or do it create a passport
well I'm gonna create a passport simply
to to annoy him and to maybe make his
developing of the pieces a little bit
harder where's the knight going nowhere
let's go b4 b5 try and kick away tonight
and try and make use of this well action
along the the C file let's go before all
the dazzling thank you for the
contribution man thanks a lot
michael botov you've becoming such a
central and prominent personality in the
chest community as you promote it with
such genuine passion and care thanks a
lot man really really appreciate it
Govardhan buddha also thank you very
much
alright so he goes for Bishop - eh not
really sure why but we're gonna wait
with b5 I'm gonna try and go for this
and then Bishop captures and then b5
should be a little bit better yeah I
thought I've actually totally missed
this so this is a quite a shame quite a
shame that I am blundering again it's
incredible
just incredible stuff
all right so we we had to give up a
piece but we still have our passport and
we do have some some okay now he gives
back the piece so I guess that's fair
probably because it's my birthday
otherwise you know he would he wouldn't
do that
all right so h4 let's win that we win
that guy and maybe add another attacker
with something like this yeah let's go
here if this I can just capture and yeah
okay he's gonna go for the pawn so I
guess we since we Queen here I guess we
keep the light square bishop so he also
covers the queening square may be
capturing with the rook wasn't a
terrible idea either
yeah but we do also owe my rook is
hanging wow I totally I'm I missed my
rook hanging as the tip of the
microphone covered it wow that's that's
super lame okay so we're preparing e7
hopefully he doesn't find a way to stop
it well that was so weird the tip of the
microphone was covering the rook and I
totally forgot it was on c1 it was
hanging for three moves yeah that's
that's bad alright let's go for this
pawn yeah I had to I had to do that and
some other pawns now as well
all right so we were able to win this
without much issues let's spin the
bishop so he cannot to go after it
yeah okay I am going to capture it let's
go here capture here kick away the king
you know it's fairly simple but yeah
that was a that was super weird
all right good game Tripp aureus was
very very interesting
Ryan Rajesh Ryan Rajesh all right man
[Music]
let's go Ryan Rajesh yes I I prefer the
black pieces in the stream yeah it was
in this position that I hang my rope
okay so maybe not for the okay let's
play one more Scandinavian no it's not
it's not vodka I I have to drive today
so not not drinking on stream especially
not alone that'd be that'd be super sad
all right
mailman incoming no the mailman was
actually here before I even started the
stream so we're good on the whole
mailman thing let's go a six thanks a
lot guys
alright so again going for this bishop
idea everyone really really going for
that so I guess we now I know that it's
actually bad
I just forgot how to play against it
yeah I'm gonna go Queen before give up
the c-7 pawn maybe try and create some
threads there yeah he plays Bishop to e3
something I don't quite get let's be
greedy or do we go greedy let's first go
like this then we're gonna capture if he
really really wants to give it up yeah
let's be greedy let's see what happens
here no no I'm not gonna be greedy first
castles then we go with the greed
there's a lot of pressure on the pawn
here so we might also pick up this one
yeah this is just I thought it's my
birthday so I should be greedy but maybe
not maybe we will see
all right so he decided to give up the
pawn let's see what happens
might be a bit dangerous
I still haven't developed my dark square
bishop but on the other hand could be
could be playable now he has to do
something and if I can get he five in
then I'm like super happy those trophies
in the background are my chess trophies
from when I was younger okay 83 ya a3 is
usually a very strong move in the
Scandinavian so I'm just gonna pick up
this guy here with Czech although then
the Queen captures it's not the best but
I did grab a pawn yeah and I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna grab another one so let's
just go here and hopefully enjoy our
extra pawn he doesn't have a way of
avoiding the trade so I'm just gonna
trade Queens and enjoy the extra pawn
Rampur thanks a lot man yes some IOP I'm
still younger okay yeah I don't know I'm
pretty sure you can capture the beat you
pawn I've just never never played like
that and I it seems to be a bit weird to
open up the file for no reason
thank you michael mossad thanks a lot
for the contribution okay so he does
avoid the Queen trade yeah I mean why
wouldn't he and now am I worried about
something not really let's play this and
if he plays yeah might even push it all
the way but not not just yet
yeah I'm gonna go Bishop to e7 too bad
too bad his Knight is guarding it
otherwise it would be it would be very
nice
f3 okay I see what you're doing here
January baby thanks a lot all right so
we're doing very well on time he's
trying to get the knight into the game
do some damage
we're just gonna trade both of the rooks
and we should be fine here
yeah that's that's good that's capture
here now he needs to get the Queen into
the game
yeah the knight is is the fine beast
however not a lot to do with it here I
guess since everything is nicely
defended yeah he wanted to check make me
here so that was super sneaky have to
have to be careful for things like that
okay so check followed by what let's go
here
yeah he's finding some unique ideas but
I'm still not interested in allowing any
counter play so let's just go here yeah
let's trade yeah that's a nice trick
however not much going on there yeah
let's capture this let's push the pass
pawn pick up the knight I guess or not
let's push it oh yeah so I was up a
piece that was that was very nice thanks
a lot man you rock is well Michael Kiki
Josie and Mohammed Allah also has the
same birthday yeah a lot of people have
have a birthday today
not not weird at all
alright so we have dark Oh dark oh let's
play against dark Oh
Darko 8:11 probably his birthday so
Darko for one does not have a birthday
today
all right so we go for the Kings gambit
again he accepts it let's see what
happens I'm gonna try and go Bishop c4
if he attacks the night I'm gonna give
up the night yeah let's just go full
development here full development we
Castle and go e5 next if he allows it
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be very
dangerous he's gonna open up the
position that way yeah makes sense he
closes up he closes up the the file
Bishop to d6 will be very nice but then
his King will have to go for a walk
solving donkey thanks a lot man also eat
green thank you for the contribution ah
he goes Bishop g7 but now I'm not going
to allow your king to Castle obviously
yeah
that was that was of course in the
position so next we go Bishop here rook
back here we put pressure on f6 or yeah
or maybe even Bishop URI a mix makes
sense okay that's that's reasonable he
wants to pick up the d5 pawn however the
bishop will hang if he moves the knight
so it's not going to happen we put
pressure here although although it's uh
it's a nice pawn I don't think I really
want to capture it okay very interesting
yeah okay I think we we do capture now
is since it does create a passed pawn
it's just too nice too nice of a move to
decline it yeah let's go all the way
let's go here
huh aha
I believe it alright so he goes all the
way here and I guess we create some
threads here
ha
all right Queen here I guess now we can
check and undable our points it's as
good a move as any since I don't want to
I don't want to overthink it but maybe
just maybe but maybe just maybe yeah
this would be playable if he what's he
doing with the Queen here why what kind
of a move is that let's try this let's
try and be super sneaky Arvind
ear thanks a lot for the contribution
man yeah my plan here is just just a
barbaric one yeah he goes for that okay
let's kick away the night all the way
push it back then I want to play Bishop
here and then I don't know it does seem
like there should be something here okay
he gives up he gives up a knight that's
something I did not take into
consideration okay because he wins my
queen that's that's the reason why
that's the reason why I missed Wow okay
but we still we still have our past pawn
so we'll we'll try and make the best of
it he wants to play this and threaten
checkmate oh this is this is just
terrible this is just terrible hmm yeah
I do have to capture oh that's that's
bad let's check in once once
try and try and block this oh yeah I
should have went for that
Queeny 7 check that I wanted to this all
this sneakiness did not pay off let's go
here we can still try and be a little
bit sneaky see I can still flag him I'm
trying to trying to do something without
actually flagging let's go let's go here
not the best now he can just capture it
yeah he just captures it and he laughs
in my face yeah that's that's what I
would do definitely yeah ok I will still
try and flag him since it's it's a
birthday stream so you know we we do
need to at least try and flag people
yeah that's that's awesome alright no I
will resign this I will resign this
d'arco good game we totally messed up
with that idea had to go for the bishop
the Queen T is 7 but I thought yeah
maybe maybe for the stream we should try
something something a bit more crazy but
a great game Darko alright you're sort
of says he he issued a challenge so let
me just try and find it alright let's go
yeah that was a devil arias alright why
didn't the challenge commence sorry
alright let's go
Lazzaro is very strong so I have to play
my best moves
let's go d5 try and get some sort of a
sort of a position let's castle here and
now try B six hopefully get the bishop
over here ah he will try to close it up
with b5 I am not familiar with this so
let's just go like this like we would in
a usual game try and get that guy into
the game okay seems seems very strong c5
c5 looks nice yeah okay let's create a
passed pawn I don't mind
he wants to trade and he does have a two
to one here so it is a bit dangerous but
we will try we will try and survive
alright let's try and get our knight in
let's push c4 let's get this night in
could be could be a lot of fun yeah if I
play this he's gonna play this also I'm
just threatening this check to pick up
to pick up the bishop which might be a
plant also I have to make some room for
my King yeah he even forces me to do it
so now that he forces me to do it I'm
not sure I want to do it yeah I'm just
gonna go for the pawn he thought I was
gonna go for the bishop but I'm actually
just gonna go for the pawn yeah threaten
the bishop now yeah so we're up upon
we're preventing him from infiltrating
with rook to d7 and now we just go
Knight back and push the passed pawn
I guess that's that's the way to go and
a six
yeah a six could be very interesting
yeah let's go check he goes back or he
goes forward yeah I don't think I I
don't think I like that for him but what
do I know
yeah that's that's a good move he wants
to get the knight here but we are going
to
huh okay so he wants to get the night
over there all right let's go here I
guess yeah he wants to go here check and
win my win my rook that's that's
terrible that's terrible man that's not
cool at all let's go here yeah he wants
to go here and I want to go move my rook
somewhere yeah I'm not gonna not gonna
let him do this yeah if he pushes b6 he
just hangs the night so I hope that's
not possible
yeah I've spent a lot of time on this I
kind of feel the tactics work in his
favor although even if they do I'm sure
I'm just gonna lose a pawn so it's not
all that big of a deal let's check this
guy here play this and push the pawn
even further let's go here threaten
checkmate and I don't think he can even
stop it okay good game man yeah that was
that was super super weird he thought I
was gonna like here yeah he just he had
a much better game I believe a much
better position but here he just thought
I was gonna go check and pick up the
bishop but it was a pawn blunder thank
you for that thank you for the birthday
wishes yours Oh Lonnie could each
creature you can also challenge yours
out of he also has a YouTube channel
with a lot of very interesting stuff on
the channel where you can learn a lot of
openings a lot of ideas so do check it
out it's a years out of chefs Channel
really really a you know a library of
information alright so what do we play
against efore we already played the
Scandinavian lesbo b6 that could be very
exciting
everyone is saying it's my birthday as
well like how many how many birthdays do
we have here okay okay
I'm reading the chat I totally missed
that he offered me d4 pawn which is
something that that can happen but
that's why we're playing this opening to
ah
you played the Owens defense a lot okay
let's yeah he goes for this he doesn't
allow me to go for it so now I am doomed
you need the wooden shield is the wooden
shield also possible if you just try and
make it with I'm gonna give up this
point it's just uh it's just in my way
like I might even give it up like this
oh no that's a free night Wow what am i
what am i saying is the wooden shield
possible also with the with the bishop
or does it have to be a queen I don't
really remember okay let's grab this guy
here
I wouldn't chill this only with the
Queen okay
I thought you could use like a bishop as
well as long as it's you know as long as
it goes all the way but if it's only the
Queen I you know yeah let's go here
that's weird but but he already gave up
a piece so I might even give up the
Queen for this rook here I mean I don't
think it would it would be that big of a
big of a deal maybe not just yet but
yeah let's just castle here
okay and he's going for for the attack
full-on so I'm just gonna try and
dislodge the night from the defense of
the rook so he has to go rook to f1 and
after he was rook to f1 he ignores me
all right no it's not it's not vodka
it's it's like it's 1 p.m. here who
would drink vodka on their birthday at
1:00 p.m. you know alone it's just
normal tap water okay
I will I will have your queen good sir
all right we will accept it I was
thinking about giving up my queen but
instead instead I ended up capturing his
so also it also works Ben says he would
definitely drink vodka alone on his
birthday that's good to hear Ben alright
so he is going for something here
alright so let's let's try and end this
as soon as possible
do I even want to defend this like I
don't think I do
ah ok I'm not alone I have you guys
that's that's true that is true okay I'm
gonna check what's the Jerome gambit
next therefore an extreme so I can
prepare it yeah it's not this is not the
rakia I would tell you guys if it was
rakia you know whenever we drink rakia
we always say we drink raki I mean let's
go for a nice check here and he has to
go back then we pick up the rook or do
we have like an instant mate I don't see
it but we will grab the rope first check
again and
meet with the third rook I suggest we
bring I know it sets the auto Queen I
mean yeah setting it to all the Queen is
fine but I don't know where where you
turn it off but it's super useful in
Bullitt so playing without Auto Queen
would be would be very weird but yeah
good game you Lani Christian I was very
intense but you you gave me a little bit
too much advantage in the opening all
right Lucy Lucy dounia's Lucy dounia's
if someone if someone can tell me in the
chat what the Jerome is I might be able
to play it
alright so everyone's playing e4 I don't
have like all that many options I'm
gonna go for the Sicilian now okay
someone mentions efore e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 oh and the
immediate Bishop captures on f7 yeah you
see the problem with that is that if I
have Bishop c5 on the board I go for the
Evans gambit so I don't see myself
playing the Jerome unfortunately as you
know it it's directly collides with my
beliefs that everyone should play the
Evans gambit alright let's capture this
since the c3 pawn has been played he
cannot kick away my queen and I'm just
gonna continue developing I think I I
don't actually ever play this with black
have no idea how to play this but I
think my Queen should go back to the 8th
at some point because it could be very
dangerous but we'll see like I have no
idea what happens if like c4 d5 is
played so I'm just completely winging it
winging it here let's go Bishop e7
castle yeah I thought it was gonna be
like a normal Sicilian but he went for
this elephant variation and I'm not not
very fond of that
but yeah I guess we're fine now
Aryan prepared the Jerome gambit for me
all right Quincy - what's Quincy - let's
let's develop the best shop get the rook
to c8 and just continue playing Sam
thank you for the contribution Sam a3
okay like before is coming I see I see
that let's go let's go rook c1 rook c8
put the rock in front of the Queen could
be it could be useful at some point and
we also want to get the Queen away from
from this rakia that makes makes sense
and now we make some breathing room for
King get rid of this bishop and
hopefully play something useful all
right so let's bring this guy here as
well
all right
okay see he wants to remove the defender
of this guy here but it's not really an
issue
okay so we've opened up our bishops
diagonal which is definitely definitely
good I'm not threatening this so he has
to deal with that if you guys hear some
Rockets there's like a bulldozer right
in front of my door you know they're
doing something repairing the road so
sorry about that
not much I can do about that all right
so of course he gets the night in here
he doesn't want to allow my queen to
enter and yeah let's try and get some
trades in here let's go night at 4:00
try and trade off the rooks and then get
to the Queen inter game yeah but how do
we do that
let's ha
it's very interesting that's actually a
mistake I'm just gonna capture here yeah
now this is a pretty big threat he has
to prevent it somehow like Queen yeah he
doesn't have this he has to go Queen
here yeah that just loses immediately
yeah good good game man
good game Lucido Gnaeus it was it was
very wild but I was able to pull it off
that h3 in the end really gave me game
my position a lot of wind thrown away
Chatterjee thank you for the
contribution man missed meeting - okay
that's fair sorry I don't see everything
I don't see most of it actually
Carla come kilometres Chris yeah now
that I know what the Jerome gambit is I
don't think I'm gonna play it since I
like I always have to play the Evans
gambit in that position like maybe we
get in Evans now no we don't he goes for
did I'm gonna go for the for the pawn
sacrifice with Bishop to c4 he doesn't
want my pawn that's that's very
disappointing let's go let's go all the
way
all right so what do we do here
that's very interesting
not allowing any sneaky ideas guarding
the d5 square let's get the night the f5
could be very dangerous I guess yeah I
guess we have to play e5 here it's it's
the way to go it just must be played
yeah sneaky ideas denied hello
I got matter Ino alright so he wants the
he wants to go he wants to trade
everything and then open up an attack
here it does make sense yeah we are
going to go back with rush of the e2 I
guess yeah captors are definitely in his
favor so we are going to go back yeah it
was almost an Italian but not really
like like a Petrov that turned turned
ugly huh you know it does make sense the
bush v6 there's a
there's no way way around it and it does
appear to be very strong
yeah let's also mess up his his Kings
position
okay maybe capturing the first was
better I have no idea why what I'm doing
but I'm actually not worried about it
I'm just gonna sacrifice the knight here
I mean the King on e6 that I mean if he
survives that he he deserves to survive
that all right so he goes in with the
knight let's block off the escape route
not allow f7 and yeah hopefully he goes
to a square that's not all that great
but yeah it's not it's not that easy to
make use of it
I'm gonna go Bishop g6 simply to guard
this square so his rook cannot enter the
game
okay let's go here so we can go Bishop
f4 and we can go bash up f5 and then we
cut off the king and the rook covers
this so maybe just maybe if he's not
careful we can even even create some
sort of a meeting threat here okay so he
realizes that it's very important to
guard against such threats but still
still let's go for it
yeah yeah let's just go like this Bishop
f4 doesn't really help me he's just
gonna block it and I don't have anything
to show for but I'm but I am very happy
with simply blocking this rope yeah
let's go
Queen d3 and the next we might even okay
that's that's interesting let's go
before and now we can open up at the
position would be five maybe get the
rook into the game yeah he did survive
but still he has to get some pieces into
the game so we'll see what he does ah he
goes here okay now Bishop f4 is very
strong and now we open up the deposition
yeah let's take away some squares from
this light square bishop first as well
yeah let's block it now the knight is
nicely pinned so the bishop repair is
working very nicely and it shouldn't be
shouldn't be easy for him to to like
develop or anything yeah let's just try
and capture that maybe open up a bit get
queenie 16 would be checkmate if
possible
okay so he goes for it now we try
something like this and hope we can get
this in if we get that in then it's just
game over we're even going to yeah we
can't have to do it like this
unfortunately I was gonna capture it
with my rook but this is also this will
also do so we go like this okay so
where's where's the meat where's the
meat here's the mate we threaten nasty
discoveries with Queen d5 does this work
sure hope it does since I'm very low on
time yeah it does all right yeah he had
to block block this mate and then I
would do some nasty discoveries with the
knight but either way kilometers Chris
thanks a lot for the game was very very
intense I messed up by not capturing any
six first but whoa but I also felt that
I also felt that that just capturing an
e6 was sufficient all right so who do we
have next Batman I think I've seen
Batman in one of our one of our
tournaments all right so Batman let's
let's do this
I'll just let it through all right all
right we have a fear supplant for the
next game
let me just check so I have to check
something
okay what the French Wow III look away
for a second and there's the French but
it's okay Equipe thanks a lot for the
contribution and the birthday wishes MLJ
also thank you very much sir
alright so which is the vinegar let's go
see five not a big fan of playing
against this but well that's weird i
don't think i i've ever played against
this it's very weird but i don't mind
yeah it's probably gonna capture on c3
and yeah but it's you know if you enjoy
playing the french then you you enjoy
weird position so that's not not a
problem at all okay so i have to be
careful for some night captures any five
ideas so i'm just gonna go back with
with my bishop yeah and he has rook c8
so i do think this is actually very
playable for him so we'll see what
happens
yeah of course rook c8 that that wasn't
even clever okay but for the moment I
don't see any good discoveries with this
Knight so not even gonna not even gonna
question my queen on c3
[Music]
night east 7 all right he's of course
going for castles and now now I am going
to shift my queen over here I don't
really enjoy it on c3
okay I may have a guest joining us for
the stream but we'll see we'll see if he
will be able to join in all right so I'm
losing a lot of time here what's what's
he playing okay so he castled just gonna
I'm gonna go h4 let's let try and make
this interesting yeah
if if night here which is probably
coming at some point okay so he goes for
this he he's baiting me to go he
captures which I will I'm definitely
gonna go for it all right so let's put
some pressure on the H pawn trying to
get him to weak in the position a little
bit more and then since he defended
properly I would say maybe just maybe
just switch it up to the queenside
okay so he shifts he shifts his forces
to the F file and hmm yeah he does have
a very strong Center I have to I have to
be careful for that and I also should
play a little bit faster so yeah okay
he's going for e he wants to play e5 and
I kind of don't want to allow that but
do I have an option eiv v I can just
play h5 I guess and then he can just
block it yeah not the greatest so let's
just go Bishop here yeah if he pushes a
45 I can then maybe capture he is not
afraid of it okay I'm not afraid of it
either let's go let's go and see what
happens yeah still cannot capture that's
the problem but I can castle here
huh all right now we really should start
playing a little bit faster oh that's
that's just bad that's just bad
yeah Bishop g4 I have f3 I'm gonna play
f3 either way so huh yeah that was a
there was a really weird weird line of
the French ya have to have to hide my
queen yeah I give up this pawn but no I
don't give it up since the Knight is
guarding it but he might be able to
overload me with like something like
captures characters could be sacrifices
could be possible yeah I am going to
trade I don't really have an option here
wow that's that's great that's actually
a pretty great move
all right now it's a flag off but he's
of course doing much better since he has
since he has a rock but night is also a
very interesting Beast
oh he flagged me oh good game man good
game Batman okay let me just let me just
check if the guest is anywhere here
still not here
market we will play a some more so he
might show up
all right good game Batman that was very
intense the French is always wild visage
alright was AK let's let's go
Adam Beaumont thanks a lot for the
contribution he's the guest Jerome no no
he isn't
no no it's not yeah now that I've now
that I know that the Jerome messes up
with the messes with the Evans gambit
move order I'm not sure I appreciate it
all that much all right
Aleksandra thanks a lot man
let's go knight c6
all right let's not not to do anything
to trade and he goes a four okay so now
I guess it's time to Castle and
hopefully get our five in to open up the
position he castles which of course
makes sense yeah it could again be
dangerous to grab this pawn but I will
grab it just to see if he knows how to
how to make use of it since everyone
gives up this pawn
of course yeah that that does make sense
and are we gonna be greedy or do we just
play normal yeah I guess we play normal
he's now going to of course do that
we're gonna trade rooks and then I
always almost always forget about this
but here it doesn't really doesn't
really work so we are going to go after
this could be very dangerous but we'll
see yeah rook characters I can go after
this and if I get my bishop removed
developed that's pretty much it that's
that's good game Nikolas all apart
thanks a lot man thanks for the
contribution and also social sake oh
thanks a lot man okay so I do get a
temple by attacking the knight and maybe
just maybe we'll be able to finish our
development okay so the knight had to
move now we open up the bishop and yeah
probably this is the next move for him
but yeah that could be could be an issue
yeah maybe grabbing that pawn wasn't the
most impressive move how about this this
could be very interesting it really
opens up my king but on the other hand
yeah not not the greatest yeah let's go
here and if rook here check everything
is on a dark square I guess it is
playable it is playable but it is super
super weird yeah let's go here so now I
can hide my king maybe get somewhere
with my bishop get the pawning so yeah I
mean this is just torturing myself for
no reason for a pawn but yeah we said we
were gonna go greedy renowned Hades
thank you for the contribution man all
right so we're doing the better on time
that's all so applause oh yeah effort
also be asking I turned 33 today so he
wants to probably do something like this
which is understandable and we are going
to yeah we don't really have any good
moves here we're just gonna allow the
Queen to enter or he wants to go here
yeah also possibility yeah Mike oh
that's the point I can't go here because
of rook there and then I lose my queen
and if Knight here see for wins the
piece so I have to go here wow this is
ugly
this is super ugly yeah he he actually
tricked me very very impressively yeah
33 is young guy I would I agree okay so
I have to go back like here and then
Queen here is like is that game I
certainly hope not
okay so I can still do this wow that's
that's bad yeah if I go here King here
yeah there's no there's no escaping this
yeah well well done well done sir well
done sir
this is truly truly impressive good game
yeah it's it never pays too big
and here you've seen why it doesn't pay
it does if you're like super careful and
you know you played the entire game
perfectly but it just doesn't pay for a
3-minute game so next game we are going
to be generous instead of greedy all
right who do we play next
filthy crank nowaday I rushed my pawns
okay I rushed my pawns why not taking
the bishop I could my I might have
missed something okay let's go yeah
let's stick with e4 ah he blundered his
bishop well I thought there was
something so seems I just messed it up
c5 okay let's again try some sneaky
sneaky ideas with b4 makes sense as he
accepts the pawn ah the the great Misha
the moderator is here hello sir 'if I've
okay let's go
Bishop b2 and mango thanks for the
contribution man and some hot chocolate
the choco bar tea also thanks a lot man
you are 18 which book should you prefer
for chess any book like if you're just
starting out any book will do you will
do you good
don't stress over it yes I got matter
with the morphe hat
yeah I should have taken the Queen in an
earlier game probably yeah don't be
greedy all right so he captures that we
can always recapture that so let's just
continue development is there a dummy's
guide to chess I don't think so
but there definitely should be one or
all done thanks for the contribution
okay so yeah that makes sense he wants
to he wants me to capture the undable
his pawns which of course I'm not going
to do just gonna move my brush back like
this and if he captures I don't really
care he develops my queen also we have
some nice threads here so yeah okay he
he spots the idea let's cast oh we can
always pick it up later yeah like he
could develop Bishop g4 but I'm not not
very convinced that it's the way to go
since after the Queen g3 you might have
some problems yeah there should be seven
let's go for four captures and then
bring the rooks into the game okay so he
castles very nicely however I do have my
two bishops which I will be very happy
to use which is the best app to practice
and learn chess I don't know if there is
such a thing at the best app okay so he
now offers me the rook by playing e5 I
can just grab it
which is what I will do as you know it's
it's a rook yeah he he castled very
nicely alright so that's a that's a fine
piece
thanks a lot thanks a lot guys all right
so he goes for the Bishop g4 move yeah
that definitely helps him I didn't
consider that although yeah there's no
way of playing that I have to go Queen
g3 then he has the capture on e5
otherwise if he moves the knight yeah I
kind of miss this but and it's funny
because I mentioned it the move before
but yeah let's capture here threaten
captures and captures and we get our
last rook into the game and we should be
should be doing very well
Cohen ferny thank you for the
contribution man all right so he moves
the bishop and now we finally bring this
guy in and we move this bishop and
hopefully hopefully make use of our
bishop pair try and make it a better
pair from hell there's no way to exploit
this I guess I guess there's no way to
exploit it let's just go back create
threats against the bishop okay so now
let's try and overload his forces with a
move like h4 always a useful move
okay I guess that's possible if I go
here he's gonna go here when my rook so
we go here yeah but then he has Bishop
f6 Wow he also has a decent Bishop pair
I have to go all the way here which is
like a terrible square let's get the
knight into the game somehow yeah once
he gets that Bishop into the game it's
not gonna be pleasant I do have to trade
here there's there's no way no way
around it and I'm down to 20 seconds
which is like so weird I'm really trying
not to get in time trouble but I just do
yeah okay he that's that's going here he
goes over there let's go over here put
pressure on the F pawn okay let's grab
okay I could have grabbed the Queen as
well so really trying not to not to mess
up
Wow I totally put the Queen there but it
didn't work but good game I rushed my
pawns
good game man oh I have to have to pre
move faster I'm actually pretty decent
at pre moving I just don't know when I
stream I totally totally mess up with
all the pre moving Muhammad ashraf let's
let's go sir yeah I don't know why like
if I play bullet I I can normally pre
move like a lot of moves but it's really
really different when you stream yeah
you're not removing in London all right
so let's oh this is a five minute game I
oh it's a five plus three Wow okay I
accidentally accepted that but we will
we will play it out
I tried cried this weird line where I
give up a couple of points for for
quicker play so we'll see how it how it
goes
yeah it's different because of too much
spelling I actually haven't had Palin in
in a very long time
all right so let's go here he wants the
yeah Trading Queens here is not the best
for me however he declined it so I guess
we we did okay yeah let's go here again
with with the weird positions
let's go here block his pawn put
pressure on this night and then I think
we're doing okay yeah the night after me
- that's one way to do it I guess yeah
we don't we what we don't want to do is
capture that's definitely what we don't
want to do
the podcast with Hikaru should be should
be fairly soon
okay f3 that's interesting I do give up
BH 7th pawn I just don't think it's like
too important of a pawn so and I'm
really not used to playing with
increment it's super weird what's the
best way to improve for a 1100 player I
would say do tactics like do tactics all
day long I think that's definitely the
best way for you to improve
all right so we already said that we
were gonna give up this this spawn we're
up a piece so I mean he does have some
pressure here although as long as my
light-square bishop is here
maybe bishop here wasn't a bad plan
trying to get rid of my bishop and
pulled this spawn I I would definitely
go with that but now as he allows it I'm
just gonna trade off all of my pieces
and enjoy you know so now if King
captures is the way to go yeah
definitely and now we need to connect
rooks definitely yeah because of that
exactly because of that so let's go here
and get more protection here also Queen
a4 check could be played how to do how
to learn tactics are there any apps for
learning tactics or do I need to learn
from books well you can pretty much just
solve them anywhere like elite chess has
solve puzzle section where you were
you're fit puzzles and you just solve
them and try to do as best as you can
or you can do puzzle rush or something
like that on chess calm but that for
that you have to pay it's like you can
do maybe three or five per day something
like that unless you're like a diamond
member so let's go here jam our Knight
over to c4 and give a check and then get
a rock into the game and should be over
fairly quickly there is literally an app
called chess tactic story I haven't seen
the app sorry about that okay so I guess
we
what's a good way to to trick him let's
go here not a lot of squares for that
Queen he could go f5 and trade it which
is definitely an option but all trades
work in my favor I should do a review of
various chest apps yeah it's definitely
an idea would be interesting at some
point I actually was planning this long
long time ago but I somehow I never got
to it but yeah and like when there will
only maybe three or four apps now there
was like a million of them so it would
definitely have something to review yeah
that's a that's a Fischer Spassky Bishop
not quite but not quite but it's it's
not a happy one didn't have of thanks
for the contribution man any chances for
an inert medina of game well we haven't
done any any Rashid sagas for quite some
time now so it it would be possible yeah
I should do a review on Stein it's yeah
Stein it says shyness tiny sees the man
may be his match against children okay
so now we can win the Queen here we can
win the Queen like this and we can win
the Queen like this so both both are
very nice although this one gives up a
rook and this one doesn't so we're gonna
go for this one
with that hat I look like a bishop okay
I will take that I will take that as a
compliment okay so it's do we need to
capture this let's give a check first
yeah
g6 and entrap the bishop also also very
possible okay so he moved do we need to
capture the Queen let's see once again
let's let's go yeah he's saying don't
take it okay so we're not gonna take it
we're gonna go here with check force him
to to go somewhere else we're not
allowed to take his queen alright but
how do we how do we win if we're not
allowed let's go here deliver this check
let's go here
and now we need some sort of a some sort
of a super move like this this is this
is really super all right
that's that's the stuff
all right so now he can get his Queen
into the game but this is very very
tough to deal with okay now he hands the
Queen so we're still not taking it we're
still just delivering checks let's let's
go for that check and hopefully get all
right so which which mate do we choose
there are so many of them so many mates
yeah I I don't don't see a good one so
we're just gonna do this one okay
good job man
it was quite a wild game wasn't very it
wasn't really used to 5+3 but yeah it it
wasn't all that bad
it just were it's weird for me since I
try like to play a move as quickly as
possible and then well I very quickly
get a terrible position since I don't
really use the increment where can you
join channel there is nowhere to join
you can just challenge me and that's it
extreme MTG everyone with E for Everyone
playing e4 okay let's I'm not gonna play
e5 although I might let's go D 5 I never
play e5 so it might might turn into an
interesting game okay let's go Knight f6
let's go for the 40 petrov and let's try
and give up a pawn maybe maybe good
things will come of it let's go here
yeah he's very aggressive very
interesting
huh
is this possible like Bishop c5 here can
it be played let's try it let's let's
try and play a fun game yeah it's only
fun if she accepts it if he plays like
yeah okay now it's now it can be fun
doesn't have to be but it could be yeah
let's not allow the King to go anywhere
near this Knight let's block off those
squares castle here and now we can get
the knight back into the game so that
was a very sneaky of me but it is a
birthday stream so I'm gonna go for the
attack on the two bishops here I don't
think he has a way of dealing with this
yeah we're gonna grab that one as well
and next we're gonna go for the rook
like this and it's it's game so here I
think I can also win the bishop now
since he allowed it so I'm gonna win the
bishop as well yes that will not do or
it might a double check Wow Wow
that's nice a double check and now a
nice mate that's what we were going for
good game mr. extreme MTG yeah that was
one one sneaky idea that paid off very
well so let's go for another one
Mysterio zijn basta rosin all right
master eosin let's try something let's
try it for
all right Knight f3 yeah it's that
Petroff line is very very tricky if your
opponent doesn't reply well so you can
try it in your own games okay so now he
doesn't want to capture on before I
actually don't really like that so I'm
just gonna just gonna do this and wow
that's a weird square for the knight
let's just continue developing
all right let's go here now the knight
doesn't have any squares to get back
into the game so it should stay there
for quite a long time
yeah like d5 here is very very very
appealing I would say yeah he goes for
it of course we could capture like
capture and then place for to really
make this night suffer here yeah let's
go this c4 and now the knight is pretty
much stranded there some I says happy
birthday tell some I thank you thanks a
lot dude if somebody wants he can he can
join me for a game as he is now a very
strong player I heard he defeated chakra
so it could be could be an interesting
game okay so I do have to block his
Bishop that's a weird arrow and I guess
yeah there's not much to do here
obviously so let's just get the knight
into the game get this night maybe two
no let's challenge the bishop that
light-square bishop is a is a nuisance
he didn't want to bring it back to b7 so
he has a square for his knight but now
I'm just gonna attack it and it's not
going to be pleasant yes
captures and captures with mate alright
so he castles he gives up the bishop he
doesn't care at all which is fine I'm
gonna I'm gonna capture it go Bishop f3
threaten this guy here also I'm taking
away the b7 square from the night so I'm
keeping the knight they're keeping the
night at bay and now we go for this pawn
which is weak probably gonna attack it
one more time
yeah but other than that he's doing very
well
like he does have these two weaknesses
but it's not not really that big of a
deal okay so now we do have a trick here
kind of we kind of do I'm trying to
connect a lot of a lot of ideas here
yeah if I capture here he goes
capped if I capture here he captures I
capture here this is under attack and
then yeah there's no there's no good way
to do it so let's just first trade this
off I thought I thought I had like a
pretty sneaky idea with something like
yeah but his thing is now on a dark
square I thought I had some like real
characters here fall by this trapping
the Queen however I don't and now it's
time to to just go back and defend or or
no maybe no yeah if I allow him to
capture it I'm gonna capture here and
here yeah that makes kind of makes sense
but then I weakened this pawn yeah this
was a yeah I was a it was a bad plan
since I pretty much allowed him to bring
his knight back into the game not what I
was going for
okay this now works for me and very
nicely yeah up until this point he had
he had a plan but again okay I would
have captured with the bishop and the
bishop everyone guards this so it's not
really an issue but let's let's not
overstay our welcome yeah we do need an
h4 move here definitely avoid any back
rank issues and now this just wins right
I guess I guess it does yeah it was very
very intense why am I not the drunk on a
birthday well I have I have much work to
do and the day is still young your son
MLP DVS thanks a lot man for the
contribution okay so he wants to trade
but I have this first check and then I
pick up the Queen and we are good that's
the stuff
let's go continue the attack maybe with
h6 even yeah he's gonna try something
but he doesn't like his position without
the Queen and it's not not surprising
okay mastery mister eosin good game man
all right still no word from our guest
which is which is weird but weird things
do happen all right so let's check out
some other challenges
let's try okay let's try a bullet one we
haven't had a bullet one in quite a
while
if there is one whenever all right a
Miniver
if he if he's online
okay he's online we still go for the for
the Scandinavian even though it's bullet
since four bullets Scandinavian does
usually serve serve its purpose yeah
yeah if it goes after the bishop we just
move it and Castle queenside and we try
and execute a five that's what we
usually want to do and four bullet it
does does make sense to do this yeah I
have to capture here oh he has that Wow
why did night why did I not see that
that's super weird yeah all this praise
of the Scandinavian and then I and then
I mess it up like this
okay so even that Wow he's not letting
me breed alright so a lot of a lot of
things happening here trying to double
up here but if he goes there of course
I'm gonna go here and double up
somewhere else I have to be careful of
these chicks here I don't want to
experience a chick and then lose
everything would be very sad yeah okay
he's going after some points which is
not a big deal let's go here yeah okay
he's going after the points I don't mind
I don't mind a lot so let's just make
room for our king should be a lot safer
there
however yeah he's gonna go yeah he can't
drop the rook because he just loses this
one so that's not gonna fly or will it
yeah good could be that it will actually
yeah I have to do this and I blunder my
own work here let's give up the rook
back check
and trade here and trying to flag him
yeah I knew that he was gonna do that so
so he does still get a queen wow this is
a master remover here a master prima
mover but I was I was able to out pre
move him yeah that was a that was pretty
pretty awesome I didn't expect that he
would be so fast and managed to get a
queen so I was just playing weird moves
but then he did and then it was like
anything anything could happen here but
yeah the the pre move war was won by me
which is great but yeah bullet is very
very stressful not for not for a
birthday stream definitely not okay so
melee Nick we're gonna play one against
millionaire
thanks a lot guys
all right is our opponent milling ik
here or not when did I start the stream
does anyone know ok so like an hour hour
and 47 minutes ago ok so I was planning
on making it like a two hour stream
since we do need to go out and have like
a nice meal and everything you know
can't just be streaming all day but I
will try and stream a little bit more I
know I don't really stream that often
thanks a lot guys ah Thank You 106
minutes that's that's really great
alright so we try a four again I mean it
just makes sense to go efore in a in a
blitz game on a stream on a birthday
again with b6 alright we're not gonna go
before let's try and play one game
without b4 I know it's not as exciting
ha a6 ok let's go h3 go for the the
Adams attack if such a thing is possible
against this g6 line I have no idea
let's castle here my king is a little
bit exposed but hopefully not too much
we'll try and get ok that's very
interesting it's very interesting ok
let's try and make this super exciting
not sure if it will be possible but just
for just for the fun of it let's see
let's see if my opponent is interested
in making this very interesting all
right let's open up the G file he wants
to open up the G file as well I'm gonna
pin him a little bit here let's go yeah
still no need to move this yeah he wants
to shift it over here so how do we
improve on this like this yeah let's not
allow it by playing this
yeah now if this I have like a clear
queen and other than that I don't know
there are of course moves he can play
but I am I am happy with how interesting
things just got
[Music]
I should try to London in the next game
okay if I get white next time I get
white we will try and go for the London
if our opponents will be will be
interested all right so let's look
that's that's OBS I'm not trying to find
OBS I'm trying to find my dashboard ah
there it is okay so h6 yes that is a
that is a fine move
however okay if I go back it's possible
but what if I capture he captures with
the bishop and I go Queen h5 does he
have a way of defending that H pawn he
does indeed he does indeed yeah he has
king h7 and there's no good way to do it
so for the moment we are going back and
yeah just gonna get king each one rook
g1 and try and try and improve on this
what's he doing with the night that's
very weird that he's doing that not
really interested in that okay maybe he
wants night b5 to c7 to trade of this
night okay that that makes sense ah he
wants to give up give up a piece to
improve his development also makes sense
okay but now I get a third attacker to
the knight here which I don't think he
will be able to handle you know I think
this is now just too much for him to
handle and I will win my piece back I
don't have much here I'm not saying I
have much here but no I don't mean my
piece back I mean I'm gonna win a piece
and it's gonna be very interesting again
I would accept an ultra bullet challenge
really I would but my PC is like super
slow I haven't upgraded it in like 10
years and even bullet when I play bullet
in a stream I feel the strain
so ultra bullet I don't think it would
be able to handle that mark was cast Evo
thanks for the contribution man thanks a
lot yeah so he doesn't have a way of
dealing with this which is a problem
okay
yeah III thought he was gonna go for
that as there is nothing better but now
it's hard to do it's hard to play of
course now that the Knight has been
eliminated of course he will not capture
as he loses the Queen now he just has to
move then comes Queen h5 and I think we
are done for this game or just I mean he
does have to do something about this
rook I guess or maybe he doesn't because
Knight captures Queen captures here I
don't really have a way of getting my
knight back into the game so it was also
possible okay so now Queen h5 is very
strong because if characters I can
capture we check and then pick up the
bishop which he allows and now he has to
give up the Queen otherwise its mate and
now we just go for this check and
they'll ever meet of course yeah check
check and mate okay and also he loses on
time so that's that's also there so a
very interesting game of course the
sacrifice isn't good but I thought it
would make for an interesting game and
it paid off at least it was it was
interesting alright so do we have any
other challenges yeah we do we do have
some challenges let's go for Claude you
okay Claude you
will I tell you the meaning of akkad
matter will not not just yet yeah time
for the London is just that I'm unblock
this game but he might go for d4 so we
might see London here if he shows up
which he is not alright so let's try
another challenge he's not showing up we
have Patrick Patrick is here yeah
closing in on it's closing in on it
alright Patrick let's go Patrick Justin
Thomas thanks a lot for the contribution
man alright so we have a d4 what do I
play on d4 I play e5 like it's a it's a
birthday stream so we should play
interesting stuff okay let's give up
this pawn as well very nice and now we
depending on what he plays we are gonna
play something as well alright I could
have gone for Bishop c5 maybe right away
but it doesn't really it doesn't really
change all that much
yeah c4 is very strong here you should
always play it against this weird idea
that I'm playing and also he checks me
okay I actually don't mind that
yeah like take it if you want I want my
bishop here my queen here my rope here
something in those in those lines okay
so now now we're gonna set a trap I'm
gonna play King here hoping that he
captures this pawn which would be weird
if he does because if he captures he
will lose a lot of material of course he
doesn't he sports my idea
and now we're gonna go for this and if
he goes 95 I can just move my night away
and get more pieces into the attack in
front of his king Noah yes thank you for
the contribution Noah and yes meadow is
the goodest boy very well said
all right so are there any reasons that
I should capture this is this night a
threat of any sort I don't think it is
at some point yeah I do want to play a
six after the shop moves yeah of course
he's gonna play that place just take
away this square from the two nights and
open up our lines of attack now we can
get the Queen in we have the bishop here
we have the knight here like everything
is just hanging I don't think I don't
think he will be able to handle this but
you never know yeah like if Queen here
what what exactly is happening this
hangs yeah I'm gonna give up the knight
actually I'm gonna give up this night
since I don't want this pawn to fall
yeah he might leak we need to now we
need to does seem like a reasonable move
but still I'm not gonna move the knight
I'm just gonna play Queen here yeah he's
going he's going for it okay so now we
need a decent move at least and we don't
have such a move like if Knight captures
here you can always bring it back but it
will be interesting so I guess we play
it let's try and play it yeah if he
captures here I don't really mind like
even if he comes therefore we're gonna
think of something yes III have faith
that we'll think of something all right
so this is a nice move f4 f4 weakens a
lot of things but it also improves a lot
of things so that's good yeah this is
actually not bad
hmm yeah this is not bad
let's try this since we we're playing in
in great style so to say so we're gonna
try and go all the way now we're gonna
go here threaten checkmate and hope he
captures here
if he doesn't capture it's gonna be very
hard to get out of it and it's not easy
to get out of it as it is like maybe
moving the rook does something but not
much yeah it was a it was a weird ok
this now just doesn't work because I
just capture and free up this square but
still it was a it was a weird plan but
it it worked out bartosh cause our
thanks a lot for the contribution man
yes there will be kick yell and I made
some cake and we haven't had any yet but
it does smell delicious so we we will
have some later Jana is pregnant
alright we are now playing a game
against the Elena alright no Coco
alright let me just find her alright
challenge Jelena let's go watch rate the
daily casual rated alright let's go
all right the game started and we have
an e4 alright so what should we do again
still enough let's let's go for a 5 all
right QE QE 100 thanks a lot man thanks
for the contribution what do I do when I
bend down and fix stuff well I I fix the
sound so so you don't hear double sound
from from the speakers there is not
really not not not much to it but I do
have to fix it you know it's not not
like a weird yeah there was the Evans
gambit opportunity let's go for this
here yeah I literally scratch my leg
let's grab this guy here push this maybe
somewhere ah
past pawn like a pawn from the past
that's a nice username
that's a nice username past pawn yeah we
had a lot of interesting porn names
okay that's annoying how do i how do I
get my Knight back that's that's super
annoying I have to go go like this no I
I don't know how to solve a Rubik's Cube
ok so this is coming what do i do then
yeah I'm gonna go here not the greatest
have to go back
all right so I can't play d5 that's a
problem because my night is hanging and
now I've placed my queen here so I can
although I don't know if I feel
comfortable with this but let's do it
now we can maybe shift the bishop in get
the rook in and maybe maybe something
happens all right Queen there what do we
have here huh do we want to go rook e8
or do we want to double up here both
ideas have their merits so to say maybe
she wants this and then go for a double
attack on the knight
so let's let's defend here and now okay
that's interesting let's go here huh and
now what now how can you improve it
chess quickly I don't think you can like
I mean it depends on how much time you
invest of course but you know you can
just improve super quickly okay so
that's the bishop goes all the way there
what do we do now huh I guess we go back
and try get this guy over here or not as
it's not allowed anymore okay so I guess
we we play b6 c5 d for something like
that that makes sense okay what did I
just blunder what was oh man i blundered
a piece wow that's bad but it can be
worse it can definitely be worse
and I'm also much worse on time which is
not something I enjoy all right Knight
here let's go back
let's capture with the rook hmm
mozzarella thanks a lot man thanks for
the contribution and trying to open up
this I'm not gonna allow it and let's go
here still down a piece ah that's that's
pretty bad okay so how do we unwind here
let's go back with the rook I guess
where is that point going let's go here
not a lot of options like maybe yeah
that kind of does make sense okay let's
just see what happens let's see what
happens and now we go back all the way
yeah f6 is very strong here like f6 is
super strong here I have to capture no
way around it and now block with the
Queen super ugly and I'm super low on
time so that's not not a lot of fun all
right
so 13 seconds for me what can I do with
13 seconds
not a lot most likely
okay let's grab that guy there and play
this check
I have zero seconds and I've removed
something I don't know I feel and I will
play it but I've removed something Wow
whoo ah he captured it yeah Wow
Jelena you had 7 seconds just pre-move
anything wow that was that was super
super weird
I've pre moved Queen Queen g4 and if you
played anything other than this she
would have won like if she played this
or this or pretty much anything it was
really really really something but the
good game Jelena maybe the game thank
you for letting me win on my birthday
that was very very nice of you all right
since we are about to go have our meal
we I'm gonna accept one more game and
that's it for this stream but we are
gonna try and do more as you guys you
guys do seem to enjoy it so let's let's
go against mr. quois
Antone Marty thanks a lot man
all right so he's not here we're gonna
try and play another one felix guattari
all right let's try Phil's guitar are
you here mr. Felix I would play the
London but I'm not getting white so all
right and again with E 5 we're just not
not getting any anything done here all
right so what will happen dommage thanks
a lot man all right let's go here arenal
all thank you for the contribution man
everyone goes for the shop c4 well not
everyone but everyone in this stream
which is which is good for me that's
music
thank you sir thanks for your
contribution let's go back and now we go
like this and it's also useful for
example when you have the bishop on c4
you can play e5 and if pawn captures
Queen goes here then you attack the
bishop and also like open up a discovery
here and now I can like just pick up
this pawn but it's again do we go greedy
or not I say we go greedy
can you see the cake oh no it's not it's
not solid yet it's still you know all
Wiggly it has to it has to cool off
orange ELISA live long and prosper as
well my friend all right
and now we can attack the bishop here or
now let's play e5 we we do need to get
that key five move in and then we move
the Queen like maybe here with okay so
he goes for the phone that's fine I
guess let's go somewhere
what's interesting so we have to play
something interesting let's attack the
knight open up an attack towards this
pawn here and try to get some some
pieces next to it it does make sense
all right so he's giving up the night
for some reason I I will take it it's
also probably another another birthday
gift so thank you for that man all right
captures I'm an excellent celebrator of
birthdays that is what I like to hear
thank you all right so let's kick away
the queen and now he places the Queen
like here on a weird square we can just
win it or if he goes yeah he's not gonna
go here obviously but yeah it is it is
unpleasant somewhat yeah okay now now I
just pick it up and you don't you do not
get to capture my knight unfortunately
next we move the King we unpin and we
should be doing well so it wasn't it
wasn't possible to go for that but I
also I also checked it if it was
possible
could I play one more match I guess I
could play one more it's not going to
not going to happen or anything let's
try this how do you yeah I accepted a
match but you were outside I don't know
how the other players would feel if we
if we did stuff like that
okay what's the idea let's let's get our
knight into the game probably something
all right what was your what was your
handle cloud you--only chess I I really
don't remember all right so let's let's
try this does anyone know what was
Claudia's handle only chess
wow I blunder the Queen yeah Wow haha
that was weird
okay but I do get to take the rook at
least so it's not all bad huh let's go
here I still have a knight and the rook
against the Queen so it's not it's not
all that bad
let's go here yeah let's go get this
check in and now threaten this pawn
maybe yeah let's do i yeah I'm gonna
capture with the night just in case
let's go here and after that I don't
really have a good reply but we can grab
this guy yeah okay I i blundered that
queen for blog thank you for the
contribution man
alright ok one more game Claude you are
close you're here ok
did you did you resign no so we play we
played the red tee
alright man let's go for it the the the
interface remember your challenge very
nice
ok so I did some studying under 80 after
my game with Maxime so I will be able to
to play some decent moves as Claudia was
outside when I accepted his match the
previous time ok my move let's go Bishop
g4 where's the dog matter is chilling in
the kitchen he's sleeping like like you
know like a log
alright let's go East 6 and hopefully
get some nice positions here yeah I'm
not worried about anything like this
since we can always challenge the pawn
but lately you know seeing Leela play
and everything moves like this doo doo
become an option definitely let's go
here now he actually might close it
Quinn goes here okay so let's just shift
now he wants to capture this okay I mean
let's go be six instead take care of c5
and well I guess it does make some sense
all right so II for finally on the board
let's let's let's capture that and after
he brings the rook into the game we
shift the other night over to f6
defender Bishop and then we figure out
how to deal with these advanced pawns
probably c5 is a move that we want to
play here as he will most likely reply
with the defo no he cannot reply he
could yeah like he could he could but
will he
interesting very interesting well let's
bring back the UH uh I was going to
attack yeah that was weird
let's just challenge that Queen and free
up the defense of this pawn and
hopefully that will be that will be
sufficient
you want to hear up a song there you go
man you think I should have played rook
to e8 first yeah possibly I don't think
it's gonna matter all that much since I
just want to pick up this pawn and then
if I can okay he's really trying to also
pick up one of the points I'm still not
gonna let him or will I huh if I go here
he's gonna go here and then all of the
pawns are defended but also this guy's
defended the sole then I go back with
the with the bishop and he goes like
here okay let's see what happens this
could be okay now just hang this pawn
wow I really shouldn't do stuff like
that
that's that's not cool really and I've
spent too much time deciding where to
where to go for it or not alright let's
let's focus here
really
so the material is equal but I am
gaining much more time which is which
will be crucial for this game I believe
alright so I will eliminate that guy
since my night isn't really all that
impressive here and shift like yeah I
first want to get rid of the Queen here
before I I don't wanna like trap Wow
okay how much how much is it possible to
blunder in one game that's that's the
actual question here okay so I'm still
gonna try and win this on time simply
because well it's the last game of the
stream which you know it's always okay
that's a free night yes we are back in
the game and threatening on f2 so we are
we are doing good work here okay
all right let's move we don't want to
blunder meat or anything yeah I actually
could trade Queens I mean I am up
material so I'm not really worried about
that let's do this trade off one of the
ropes go here yeah I don't think he will
be able to flag me I am a pretty quick
free mover the longer the stream goes
the quicker I pre move and I've just
wandered my rock yeah do not caption
that alright a good game you you
basically won but I won on time but this
is your game yeah that's that's the
stream I do hope you enjoyed it I
enjoyed it immensely and I'm now going
to have you know some other some other
content planned for my birthday so we're
gonna we're gonna see each other some
other time when I make the next video or
when I stream another time so once again
thank you all for joining I really
enjoyed it
of course you can always check my two
previous videos here and I will see you
guys very soon
see you guys